[Musique]
merci Pierre ouia nous accompagné
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu des hautes scènes membrre du
groupe communiste et tout nouveau
vice-président du Sénat on va évidemment
voir l'actualité avec vous on l'a vu
dans le journal hier ellisabeth borne
réunissait une cinquantaine de personnes
ministres maire association
parlementaires pour faire le diagnostic
3 mois après les émeutes dans notre pays
est-ce que c'est trop tard 3 mois après
d'être encore à l'heure du diagnostic
ben bien sûr le diagnostic est est connu
euh j'ai vu sur votre écran mon mon ami
le maère de nanre Patrick Jarry qui
était candidat avec moi au au sénatorial
ça fait des années qu'il pose un
diagnostique diagnostique est connu ce
qu'on veut c'est un plan un plan
interministériel qui permette de de
résoudre un certain nombre de mots
sociaux de de ces communes populaires
alors le plan c'est pour fin octobre
elle annonce pour le le 30 octobre
qu'est-ce que vous attendez-vous de ce
plan mais souvenez-vous il y avait le
plan borlau il a fini à la poubelle donc
ce que je crains c'est qu'il se passe la
même chose ce qu'on ce qu'on a besoin
maintenant c'est un plan pluri
pluriinistériel pour attaquer l'accès au
service public c'est ça qui est
fondamental l'accès au soins l'accès à
l'éducation l'accès au transport l'accès
au logement il faut des solutions
concrètes sur ces quatre points avec
priorité sur le logement notamment le
logement en région parisienne c'est
c'est ce qui pose le plus de problèmes
on va parler des questions ation puisque
c'est un sujet que vous suivez
particulièrement hier le ministre de
l'Éducation Gabriel hatal a donné une
interview au journal Le Monde il annonce
le lancement d'une mission exigence des
savoirs avec priorité le français et les
maths nous devons engager une bataille
pour le niveau de notre école c'est ce
qu'il dit il vous trouvera à ses côtés
dans cette bataille mais même chose même
chose depuis depuis que Macron est au
pouvoir on en est à à combien de plans
souvenez-vous il y avait eu un grand
plan de Cédric vellani pour les
mathématiques le résultat c'est que on a
permis à des à des lycéens en terminal
DEP faire de math quelle catastrophe
donc là aussi on n pas besoin de de plan
d'unè plan non ce qu'il faut c'est des
moyens pour en effet relever le niveau
parce qu'il y a un problème de niveau
faut dire les choses le niveau baisse
mais comment alors mais euh dans le
discours de Monsieur hatal il y a un
point qu'avait très courageusement
évoqué son prédécesseur et que lui ne
reprend pas c'est celui de la mixité
scolaire il est il est un élu des hautes
scènes il sait très bien que dans les
hautes scènes il y a aujourd'hui une
forme de séparatisme scolaire il y a des
des établissements pour les riches et
des établissements pour les pauvres et
alors il en parle hein mais il dit
l'origine sociale c'est pas le seul
problème il dit dans une classe à
origine sociale égale dans la même
commune il y a des grandes différences
dans les notes des élèves mais ce qu'
dit c'est qu'on peut faire on peut faire
face à ces problèmes par la par la
pédagogie je n'y crois pas je n'y crois
pas je n'y crois pas tant que les
établissements privés essentiellement
capteront la totalité des des élèves qui
pensent PIR pou voir réussir on n'y
arrivera pas ce qu'il faut c'est
réintroduire de la mixité sociale au
sein des classes j'ai fait une
proposition de loi là-dessus je lui
demanderait son avis on doit
l'auditionner la semaine prochaine avec
la commission de avec la commission de
la culture tout à fait qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de cette audition mais qui
me répondent à ma question le son son
prédécesseur avait eu quelques idées
très courageuses est-ce qu'elles sont
encore d'actualité moi je suis
intimement persuadé que c'est la façon
dont de dont son
prédécesseur souhaite été imposé à
l'enseignement privé un certain nombre
de normes sociales qui a fait son
inviction de gouvernement donc je
poserai la question comme ça sur le
niveau des élèves il pose cette question
peut-on continuer à laisser passer en 6e
des élèves qui ne savent pas lire écrire
et compter quelle est votre réponse à
Ben comment ça se fait qu'on narrive pas
en en CP à faire apprendre à lire à
écrire à tous ces gamins c'est là qu'il
faut commencer le le problème c'est
c'est c'est c'est celui-là parce qui
donne des des des c'est quand même assez
alarmant ce qu' dit à l'entrée en 6e un
élève sur ne sait pas l correctement un
sur de ne sait pas dire combien il y a
de quart d'heure dans la fraction TR qu
d'HE on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est catastrophique mais
bien sûr c'est rattrapable d'autres pays
on fait on fait des des choix différents
des nôtres ça a marché mais après nous
nous avons l'école que nous méritons en
France dans l'OCDE c'est sans doute la
France qui met le moins d'argent sur sur
son école primaire donc les résultat est
là vous savez en matière scolaire c'est
très simple vous mettez des moyens ça
marche vous en mettez pas ça ba c'est
aussi simple que ça la clé c'est aussi
évidemment le nombre d'enseignants le
nombre de professeurs d'élèves par
classe et d'élèves par classe alors là
il dit effectivement que ça a baissé et
qu'on peut revoir les choses en faisant
des classes par groupeou on est pas dans
la moyenne européenne hein on est encore
plus haut hein sur sur l'attractivité il
faut lever tous les freins pour réussir
à recruter au moins 100000 professeurs
sur le quinquena c'est ce qu'il dit
c'est atteignable pour vous comme
objectif oui à la seule condition que on
fasse confiance aux enseignants voilà
les enseignants sont fatigués de de
recevoir des normes nationales qui
doivent appliquer comme de simples
exécutants un enseignant c'est un
créateur devant une classe c'est une
classe qui est toujours très différente
qui peut être totalement différente
entre la corise et et les hautes scènes
donc je pense sincèrement qu'un
enseignant c'est un artiste il faut il
faut absolument le laisser s'exprimer
pour ça faut lui faire confiance dans sa
dans sa pédagogie et pas lui donner des
circulaires qui changent tout le temps
en permanence ça c'est pas possible sur
le pacte enseignant puisque ça fait
partie des dispositifs évolu par le
gouvernement ça permet de toucher une
pre manuelle en échange de mission
supplémentaire c'est la bonne réponse
mais non c'est un échec c'est un échec
on l'a bien vu les enseignants ne
souhaitent pas rentrer dans un système
de contractualisation ce sont des
fonctionnaires qui sont au service d'un
service public service public qui doit
être national on peut pas le décliner en
fonction des uns et des autres dans
chaque établissement on va continuer à
parler de ces questions d'école c'est
aussi l'actualité dans nos régions on va
à Marseille on retrouve Léo purguette
bonjour Léo merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous président et directeur éditorial du
Journal La Marseillaise et on revient
avec vous Léo sur les menaces de ferme
d'une antenne de l'université d'ex
Marseille et ça c'est pour des questions
de sécurité
oui c'est directement lié à l'extension
du trafic de drogue dans notre ville qui
et bien la perturbe a fait couler
beaucoup de sang depuis maintenant des
années il semblerait que et bien cette
logique he de recherche de nouveaux
marchés qui est suivi par les
trafiquants de drogue sans limite et
bien s'étend jusque devant des serv
public puisquen effet une crèche mais
aussi la faculté Colbert ont dû fermer
leurs
portes un moment pour se se protéger
hein contre ces trafiquants il y a une
réaction assez forte de la préfecture de
police qui a mis en place
une brigade statique devant
l'établissement et de la municipalité
qui a insister sur le fait que les
services publics ne pouvaient pas
reculer face au trafic on sait que c'est
une question
qui a longtemps étéit tabou à gauche et
sur laquelle je voulais entendre votre
invité le sénateur
ousouia qu'est-ce que la Gauche propose
et bien pour mettre un terme à ces
trafics qui pourrissent la vie des
quartiers les plus populaires et qui
aujourd'hui déborde jusqu'en
centr-eville d'abord je je suis très
heureux de voir que derrière vous il y a
la Une de La Marseillaise au moment de
la libération de de Marseille avec la
citation des FTP ça me fait ça me fait
plaisir ce que ce que je an moi à
Marseille et puis chez moi à Bagieu
c'est que les gens ont besoin et exigent
de la sécurité et ils ont besoin d'une
police de proximité qui soit là en
person en permanence et qui les protège
parce que là j'ai compris que la brigade
statique elle serait provisoire
oninstalle pas un commissariat hein donc
pendant quelques temps les trafics vont
vont partir ailleurs et puis une fois
que la brigade sera partie ils vont
revenir ce qu'on veut c'est une
installation pérenne d'une police de
proximité qui permettent aux gens de
vivre en sécurité c'est ça ce que les
gens demandent mais Léo vous voulez
intervenir encore parce que sur ce que
disait Léo sur le fait que cette
question de la sécurité a été longtemps
tabou à gauche oui est-ce que la gauche
a trop tardé à s'emparer de ces
questions de sécurité mais bien sûr non
mais bien sûr je je pense que il y a
deux sujets je je crois qu'on peut on
peut considérer que la police n'est pas
n'est pas là pour faire régner un ordre
social et ça c'est important en revanche
elle est là pour faire RER un ordre
républicain c'estàd assurer à chacun la
possibilité de vivre tranquillement dans
son quartier un ordre social
c'est-à-dire museler les les
revendications sociales quand le
gouvernement estime que toute façon il
il pourra pas les satisfaire ça c'est
pas le rôle de la police c'est pas le
rôle de la police la police elle doit
être au service de la population donc
directement sur le terrain et ça je
pense que c'est une idée de gauche
Léo oui ben je voulais interroger aussi
le sénateur sur ce qui fait notre une
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire la Fête de la
Science là aussi il y a
finalement une forme de divorce entre
une partie de la gauche et cette science
ça s'est vu au moment des campagnes de
vaccination mais aussi sur d'autres
sujets ayant tré à l'environnement
comment retrouver un rapport sain entre
la science et la population alors je
suis je suis
vraiment très interrogé par par la
rupture vis-à-vis de la rationalité en
général la République française c'est la
fille des lumières donc elle a posé
comme principe la rationalité une
certaine confiance dans le progrès
scientifique dans la technologie et
aujourd'hui on on voit en effet vous
avez parfaitement raison que il y a une
il y a une rupture très forte donc la la
solution c'est redonner toute sa place à
la science et surtout redonner toute sa
place aux enseignant et aux chercheurs
ça je pense que c'est fondamental quand
un jeune chercheur qui rentre au CNRS
est payé à une fois et demi le SMIG
quelle confiance vous pouvez lui faire
aujourd'hui c'est considéré comme un
travailleur comme les autres il faut
redonner de la valeur à tout ça et ça
c'est un immense travail à faire
notamment à gauche notamment à gauche
vous avez parfaitement raison et c'est à
la Une de La Marseillaise Léo on la
regarde la fête de la science à vos
marques c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup merci Léo purgette merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin à très
vite évidemment dans cette émission on
va parler de l'Arménie pierreousouia
évidemment sujet que vous suivez là
aussi et cet exode forcé des Arméniens
du haut carabach la France affirme son
soutien à l'Arménie hier Emmanuel Macron
qui était à Grenade a dit qu'il fallait
continuer à discuter avec l'Azerbaïdjan
on va parler de tout ça Quentin calm
nous
[Musique]
rejoint bonjour Quentin bonjouran
bonjour pierreouia bonjour et Quentin la
France est pointée du doigt par
l'Azerbaidjan depuis de jours voilà les
propos de Catherine Colona passe mal
pour rappel la chef de la diplomatie
française était en Arménie cette semaine
la ministre qui a rencontré son
homologue en Arménie et qui a visité un
hôpital pour grand brûler aussi à ervan
avec la ministre arménienne de la santé
et à cette occasion elle a assuré le
pays du soutien continu je cite de la
France quatre patients vont même être
reçus dans des hôpitaux français au
total l'aide de Paris atteint déjà 12,5
millions d'euros une aide humanitaire
mais pas que la France exprime depuis
plusieurs jours son inquiétude sur une
possible offensive militaire de
l'Azerbaïjan contre l' contre l'Arménie
la ministre est donc allé encore plus
loin cette semaine écouez catherrine
Colona je voudrais indiquer publiquement
que la France a donné son accord la
conclusion de contrat
futur forgé avec l'Arménie qui
permettront la livraison de matériel
militaire à l'Arménie pour que elle
puisse assurer sa défense vous
comprendrez que je ne puisse pas entrer
dans plus de détails pour le moment
cette déclaration a fait bondir les
officiels azerbaïdjanais il devaient
participer à une réunion avec des pays
européens cette semaine en Espagne
c'était même prévu hier le président de
l'Azerbaïdjan qui a annulé sa venue
jugeant le soutien des Européens trop
marqué à l'égard de l'Arménie une vraie
crise diplomatique en somme même si hier
l'Azerbaïjan s'est dit prêt à des
pourparler avec l'Arménie sous médiation
de l'Union européenne Orian et Quentin
on parle souvent ici de la fameuse
diplomatie parlementaire alors que peut
faire le Sénat bien depuis plusieurs
semaines même plusieurs mois certains
parlementaires alertent sur la situation
dans le haut carabak Bruno rotaillot
chef de fil DLR au Sénat avait même
exhorté l'exécutif français dès la fin
mai on est à la veille d'une tragédie
avait-il dit lors des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement déjà le
sénateur de vandet parlait d'épuration
ethnique à l'époque un terme que les
officiels français commencent à évoquer
eux-mêmes écoutez à nouveau la chef de
la diplomatie c'était hier soir sur
France 2 sur ce terme très précis
d'épuration ethnique au haut carabak
peut-on parler selon vous d'une
épuration ethnique ça y ressemble en
tout cas un exode forcé des gens qui
doivent quitter leur terre ancestrale
leur foyer après des opérations
militaires ou sous la menace de
nouvelles opérations militaires ce sont
pas des départs volontaire même s'il
faut garder l'espoir bien sûr qu'il
reviennent un jour dans ce qui est leur
foyer ancestral donc ce terme vous le
validez cette expression on peut le
valider j'ai employer souvent le mot de
crime pour employer celui de tragédie
également certains sénateurs se mobilise
toujours à droite on parle de Valérie
Boyer elle demande à Emmanuel Macron de
geler les avoirs du président de la zer
bjan de renvoyer l'ambassadrice de ce
pays de mettre l'Arménie sous protection
internationale ou encore de faire cesser
l'achat du gaz
azerbaïdjanais russe c'est son
expression on verra dans les prochaines
semaines quelles sont les initiatives
prises par le Parlement mais Pierre
rousouia qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire
qu'est-ce que le Sénat qu'est-ce que le
Parlement peut faire dans cette crise
moi j'ai honte de de ce qui se passe
parce que ça fait 3 ans depuis la guerre
de 2020 que nous alertons le
gouvernement français et puis la mission
européenne sur ce qui va ce qui va
arriver et ce qui s'est passé c'estàd
qu'on a laissé l'Azerbaïjan prendre par
la force un un territoire qui avait voté
son indépendance dans un cadre tout à
fait lécal il faut le redire les
frontières de mais qui n pas connu just
pierre ouulen oui pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi nous ne nous reconnaissons les
frontières internationale de l'Ukraine
et pas celle de hautkabach l'artsar en
en arménien je je ne comprends pas cette
raison donc l'Azerbaïjan par la force a
pris un territoire pour en évacuer les
100000 les 120000 Arméniens quand un un
dictateur vous dit qu' il continuera le
génocide de 1905 comment pouvez-vous
rester lui faire confiance ce n'est pas
possible c'est une évacuation l'Arménie
est face à un problème énorme elle va
être obligée de satisfaire des besoins
de 5 % de sa population supplémentaire
on doit l'aider et par ailleurs la
ministre a raison l'Azerbaïjan a commis
un crime le crime ne doit pas rester
impuni la seule façon aujourd'hui de
défendre l'Arménie c'est de faire payer
à l'Azerbaïjan son crime et il faut des
sanctions est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque
d'escalade notamment aussi en envoyant
des des armes qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de la réponse de la France sur ce
dossier mais je pense que le la première
chose à faire ça serait que la France
demande un embargo sur la livraison des
armes en Azerbaïdjan Israël continue à
fournir très régulièrement l'Azerbaïjan
not notamment en drone première chose
deuxième chose Israël qui est voilà
allié avec l'Azerbaidjan car aussi l'EMI
iranien aussi dans derrière il y a
l'énergie il y a un calcul terrible où
on vend le destin de 120000 personnes
contre des fournitur de gaz et de et de
pétrole je trouve ça absolument honteux
moi je trouve ça horrible c'est
complètement inqualifiable donc il faut
aider l'Arménie à se défendre et surtout
il faut obtenir une sanctuarisation des
frontières internationales de l'Arménie
parce que ce que l' gererb a fait dans
dans l'karaba demain elle fera en
Arménie nous nous prenons ici je je je
prends fait t causes pour l'Arménie
c'est encore une fois ce qui va arriver
et on leur a dit une nouvelle fois donc
une extension du conflit une extension
du conflit tout à fait la Russie est en
train de quitter le caucas du Sud donc
il y a plus rien à attendre de la Russie
il faut que l'Europe aujourd'hui assure
la protection de l'Arménie c'est
indispensable justement c'était ma ma
question suivante la la France qui se
plaint aussi de de du manque de
solidarité des partenaires européens
dans ce dossier il y a un dilemme en
fait on comprend pour l'Union européenne
avec l'achat de ce gaz qui vient
d'azerbaïjan comment est-ce qu'on peut
démêler ce nœud européen mais moi
j'aimerais rappeler que l'Allemagne a
organisé sa dépendance au gaz russse VO
et qu'ensuite elle a cherché à trouver
d'autres d'autres approvisionnement
notamment par rapport à à l'Azerbaïjan
ce qui a fait que la présidente de la
Commission européenne a qualifié
monsieur alief le dictateur alief de
partenaire fiable elle s'est rendu même
à B coup effectivement monsieur alief a
compris qu'il pouvait envahir le
hautkarabach c'était une forme
d'impunité qui était achetée par par le
gaz il faut faire très attention dans
l'espace post-soviétique il y a d'autres
cas similaires et si on considère que la
force est finalement le moyen de
résoudre les problèmes de nationalité
dans l'espace post-soviétique nous
allons vers des crises majeures et
possiblement indémantellement de ce
qu'est la Russie aujourd'hui qui ne va
satisfaire personne et
la France Quentin le disait a envoyé du
matériel en tout cas promis la livraison
de matériel militaire à l'Arménie mais
est-ce qu'elle est en capacité d'assurer
sa défense l'Arménie non aujourd'hui non
non parce que derailleurre l'Azerbaidjan
vous avez la Turquie hein il faut ouvrir
les yeux vous avez la Turquie qui elle
est dans son projet post post ottoman
qui est de de faire une continuité
territoriale entre la Turquie jusqu'aux
République turcophone d'Asie centrale
c'est ça le projet donc le projet c'est
de couper en deux l'arme pour permettre
l'organisation d'un d'un corridor face à
l'armée Tuque bien évidemment que
l'Arménie résistera 24 heur comme comme
leabach là-dessus c'est une évidence
donc ça suffit pas non ça suffit pas il
faut un engagement de l'Europe mais
d'abord faut des sanctions il faut que
la zerbadjan paye son crime à propos de
du okaraba on entendait Kaine Colona
hier sur France 2 pensit que les les
familles allent pouvoir un jour
retourner dans ce territoire est-ce que
ce ce cette cette c'est possible selon
vous non parce que il y a une autre une
autre enclave azérie dans le dans le
territoire d'Arménie qui est le
naritevan quand Staline a donné le
naritevan à l'Azerbaïdjan il y avait 90
% d'Arméniens aujourd'hui il n' reste
pas un seul donc les Azéris feront
rigoureusement la même chose
malheureusement c'est un pays qui
disparaît sous nos yeux ça me je trouve
ça complètement immoral c'est
insupportable sur nos relations avec
l'Azerbaïdjan Emmanuel Macron lui dit
qu'il faut pas rompre le dialogue qu'
faut continuer à discuter avec
l'Azerbaïjan parce que c'est le meilleur
moyen de protéger l'Arménie vous nêtes
pas d'accord avec ça il faut un rapport
de force il faut un rapport de force
faut pas couper les P il faut continuer
di jamais mais dans une négociation faut
un rapport de force donc il faut
commencer par des sanctions c'est ce qui
permettra de mettre les azérries autour
de la table sans rapport de force on
nobtiendra jamais rien merci conttin
merci tout àhe oui on va parler du
Conseil national de la refondation poste
etmeut on était à matinon hier vous y
étiez vous nous raconterz ça absol tout
à l'heure dans le club merci à tout à
l'heure Quentin euh on va terminer en
parlant du Sénat pierre rousouia vous
devenez euh vice-président du Sénat vous
êtes le le vice-président communiste
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous
beaucoup de choses vous savez je suis
moi je suis issu d'une d'une famille
paysane du plateau de milvache donc je
suis passé du du plateau de milevache au
plateau du Sénat entre les deux il y a
toute une histoire familiale et je pense
à à mon arrière grand-père fusillé par
les Allemands à mon grand-père colonel
FTP et cetera c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion après beaucoup de
responsabilité je je n'oublie pas d'où
je viens que vous comptez exercer
comment il y a une forme d'inquiétude un
peu d'angoisse de ce nouveau rôour parce
que c'est parce que l'institution
sénatoriale est est très intimidante
elle a elle a ses codes ses façons de
faire dont on doit s'imprégner
progressivement mais c'est une
institution qui qui permet une très
grande liberté de parole à condition
qu'on l'exerce dans les règles qui sont
qui sont pas toujours écrites et c'est
sans doute la difficulté de de
l'exercice donc il faut que je fasse ça
sans oublier d'où je viens et et et ceux
qui m'ont élu ça c'est fondamental le
groupe communiste justement auquel vous
appartenez qu'on disait avant les
élections sénatoriales possiblement
menacé finalement il s'est renforcé vous
êtes sauvé pour au moins 6 ans pour le
coup vous êtes soulagé alors à chaque
élection on nous promet notre
disparition et régulièrement on se
renforce donc il faut oublier il faut
oublier ça non mais bien sûr nous sommes
nous sommes 18 c'est important sommes un
groupe qui progresse dans une gauche qui
progresse au Sénat on l'a pas assez dit
he mais on va en parler la gauche
sénatoriale qui gagne des sièges tout à
fait sans la France insoumise puis que
vous avez refusé l'alliance avec la
France insoumise ça veut direun ça
fonctionne s la France sû moi j'ai fait
l'union de la gauche dans dans mon
département la franceoumise aussi veut
l'union de la gauche he mais avec vous
vous dites ça fonctionne sans vous
peut-être pas la même moi dans mon
département j'ai fait l'union de la
gauche des radicaux de gauche jusqu'à
Génération Écologie les socialistes les
ver il y avait tout le monde la France a
soumise à a refusé d'y participer je le
regrette vous savez moi je suis moi je
suis de l'ancienne école mais c'est eux
qui ont refusé ou c'est vous qui qu' on
refusé non non c'est eux qu' ont refusé
bien sûr moi je suis de l'ancienne école
il y a il y a deux références absolues
pour moi c'est 1936 le Front populaire
l'union de la gauche de d'allad à
Maurice Torz et 1980 l'union de la
gauche de Robert Fabre à George
marchetis ben c'est ça que c'est vers ça
qu'il faut aller c'est ouvrir une gauche
qui puisse un jour être majoritaire
alors ben manuel bonpard le coordinateur
de la Franceis vous l'imaginez il est
pas d'accord avec vous hein hier il
était à votre place il nous disait que
si vous n'aviez pas refusé l'Union la
gauche sénatoriale aurait s sièges
qu'est-ce que vous dites mais mais
mais je je peux renvoyer les écrits que
j'ai obtenu de la France insoumise dans
les hautes scènes c'est eux qu'on
refusait le N al le vous c'est général
hein c'était pas vous qui cétait
communistes je vois que mon collègue du
valdoise a été sur été élu sur une liste
où il y avait la France insouis c'était
possible pourquoi ils l'ont refusé moi
j'attends toujours la réponse euh que ce
que je sens c'est que il y a des
partenaires de l' nuub qui sont
parfaitement légitimes pour réaliser
l'union et d'autres qui sont moins ben
nous nous les communistes notamment donc
ça ça fonctionne pas voilà et par
ailleurs dans l'union de la gauche il y
a des diversité il faut qu'elle
s'exprime parce que c'est notre richesse
c'est ce qui permet de construire une
gauche plurielle une expression qui a
fait son temps un dernier mot sur les
communiste parce que pour Manuel bonpard
on sait que c'est un petit peu tendu en
ce moment entre Fabien Rousel et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour Manuel bonpard
Fabi est sortie de la Nupe est-ce que
vous considérez ça aussi est-ce qu'il
faut clarifier la situation au PC non ce
qu'on ce qu'on cherche et c'est ce que
j'ai fait encore une fois dans mon
département c'est un élargissement de
l'Union de la gauche voilà il faut aller
chercher tous les partenaires parce que
on peut pas se satisfaire des 23 vous
pouvez continuer dans les invectives
entre Fabien Roussel et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et dire bon ben on reste quand
même dans laanupe moi je suis petit fils
de résistant communiste ah et quand on
on traite mon secrétaire général de
dorotiste je ne peux pas l'accepter je
ne peux pas l'accepter il faudrait qu'il
comprenne qu'il touche à quelque chose
qui est extrêmement fort chez nous la
culture de la résistance elle est
absolument fondamentale pourquoi ne pas
acter la S avec alafi mais parce que
parce que nous tenons à l'union de la
gauche voilà et dans l'union de la
gauche nous n'excluons pas la France
insoumise contrairement à à ce que je
peux entendre merci Pierre merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première dem